Yeah, well it's, if it didn't
exist, it would be way more
interesting than bigfoot.
Yeah, right. Like everybody's like so
into big foot being real. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't get big plays. Can you talk to
me about that? Like do you think what,
what is, what's the concept
of big fight? I mean, I know,
okay. It's a big hairy guy,
but yeah. Well, I mean really come on.
What is it most likely there
was interaction between
human beings and something
called the gigantic Opeth Agus for
thousands and thousands of years.
It's a giant bipedal hominid that existed
in Asia that was between eight and 10
feet tall. It was real and it was
basically in like the orangutan family.
It looks almost orangutan like, but
enormous. And that was a real thing.
And they didn't find out about this until
like the 1920s they found a tooth in
an apothecary shop in China and a,
and anthropologists examined his tooth.
It was like, where the fuck
did you get this? And they,
they took them to the site and they dug
up more things and bones and jawbones
and they determine from the job on,
I'm sorry if I'm fucking
any of this up scientists,
but they determined from the job
on that they think it was bipedal,
that it stood up on two
legs and so then they said,
well how big would this thing be?
And then in the proportionate, yeah,
like the feelings. Are you ever seen
one? A real one looks like? Yeah. I just,
sometimes when they say like,
oh up in Michigan, I'm like,
is it really like what are they saying?
Bullshit.
Most of it is the people
seeing shadows in the trees.
They want to believe it's big foot and
they're seen bears that are walking on
two legs.
But if there was a thing,
what's really interesting is that's
where it would be because if it did come
across the larynx, the Bering land
bridge, like they believe humans did.
If that did happen, the many animals
Maton navigated from there to here.
That way.
That's where Alaska and
the Pacific northwest,
that would be the natural path.
And then if you think about how
densely wooded that area is, right,
that would be a natural habitat for
something that's hiding from people.
The problem is you can't really hide
from shit anymore. It's just too hard.
They'd see from space up, something
would catch you on a trail camera.
Some,
there's trail cameras that are everywhere.
They're four k like did you see those?
These a guy and his father got caught
poaching of mother bear in her den.
It's ill, it's horrific, it's horrible.
And it's not just horrible because the,
they poached this mother bear in their,
Dan left the babies essentially to die.
But they were talking about how they're
not going to get caught doing it.
Like no one's gonna tie us to this.
And the way they were caught,
there was a four k camera that
was right behind them that was,
that was observing this, this whole
area where this does bear was den,
den. They have these trail cameras
now. They're incredibly accurate.
There's so like, it's so
high definition, right?
We're super clear on the audio is clear.
Would catch one of those fucking things.
Yeah.
Out then.
But I think there is something to
be said for the tooth fairy and
thinking we don't know
everything like them.
The magic of stuff on known and behind.
I mean for me it doesn't have
to be big foot, but I I love,
I love the idea that we haven't seen
everything. We don't know everything.
And obviously we know that was
space and who knows, you know,
dimensions and time and universe,
but something mythical is pretty fun.
Well,
what's interesting is that there was
a bunch of different kinds of humans.
That's what's interesting.
And they found these bones in Russia
that I think they call them the dentist
Soviet [inaudible]. They found a coco.
This is within the last 10 15 years.
They found a completely different
species of humans that lived in Russia.
They found those little people on the
island of Flores that was only like 10
years ago.
I mean there's,
there's probably dozens more that
they just haven't uncovered somewhere.
So if there was at one point in time,
some big giant Hominid,
it's totally possible.
I just don't think you'd have
to eat so much to be alive.
10 feet have constantly,
it's like a bear. Yeah.
Like you find bear shit everywhere.
Where's the, where's the gorilla? Shit?
Where's the the big foot shit? Whatever
it, is it city? Is it eating plants?
Is it any animals? What the fuck
is it? Eating right can eat a lot.